[Music]
in two against one
muse threesome by cold in magic card I
don't know for those I bet two against
one
watch type in two verses mod and horn
you're gonna see a threesome okay my bad
a father and son duo beat up a random
gamer over a dispute about the Pokemon
Cody Castle hi let's try to fight they
[ __ ] fought over Pokemon Dan son
though they pretty much jumped this dude
Oh No Magikarp ate the fish how old this
is dude an adult what it's like sad why
oh no like 70 and 30 oh my god how did
you know oh my god [ __ ] exactly in 1 in
30 years old why is that why is that sad
that's funny
well how old is the dude that got beat
I'm imagining I'm imagining they're at
the beach and then they're like that's
my [ __ ] magic carpets 9 and a bumper
button again to for the guys like 19
actually they don't mention that they
[ __ ] up a six year old I bet you was
like a six year old game no I mean it's
an adult
that's funny then getting beat up by
seven year old us fighting 71 and a 30
years Danny's got a nose the cow nose
rings [ __ ] Tupac septum the septum
ring like a cow how's this sad no I'm
just see there's because barking old
they're old and he shouldn't be doing
[ __ ] like this a 70 year old getting
into fight is hilarious which she didn't
say it's hilarious ed it was sad like
pathetic it's pathetic
that's what I mean by face dammit
compute is sad about that situation
Larry yeah that's what makes him funny
we find the [ __ ] gold and everything
[Laughter]
yeah so anyway so this dude the victim
he was at this like Park area and he was
he was taking over what does it call
like Oh Jim Pokemon go Jim yeah so you
know okay have you played Pokemon go so
it's like GPS okay
I should play pokemon go you got boring
remember it is boring still but I do
those will be three mile walk anyway
then yeah yeah I never planned I guess
you can see like Pokemon you could catch
them and all those things at certain
locations they have these jams and then
you can battle your Pokemon to take over
that jamming so apparently this dude had
just taken over that gym and so there's
71 and 30 year old oh they're in a
relationship for sure
its father and son like in a intimate
relation you're talking about what do
you call it
incest yeah that's gross just cuz
they're white that's a good point
they didn't look away yeah he doesn't
look white it looks like that Boy Meets
World guy Fred Savage
but Savage no that's not it been savages
that one when Fred is the older one so
I'm so waiting for the sad part what's
the sad part it's pathetic that through
that old yeah I do remember to use the
wrong words yeah wasn't pathetic so what
do they do so they they found Freddy the
fact that they're playing Pokemon the
pathetic details old people aren't
allowed to have hobbies is that we're
trying to say no so I'm about to tell
you so then the victim
doesn't mean that you're [ __ ] smart
and mature okay
there's people that made 70-year
mistakes and they're still fuck-ups oh
yeah
like you found 80 years old tell me I'm
not allowed to spray-paint shoes yeah
why I mean like Wyatt why is the 70 year
old carrying so much [ __ ] high cuz he
wants to design his own shoes got a card
so this is the area where this took
place look at Japan that's where the
shot laughs samurai I want a backyard
like that people do yeah so the incident
approaching the victim beating him up
and they gave him a whole bunch of it
he's got a lip or a [ __ ] I was like
this man has a person does looks like a
lip but picture upside down and in like
a little ghost yes that sure looks like
a lip just like this sideways and it's a
really [ __ ] up Brazilian dude it's a
weird place on the side to shave one
side of it
they're gonna often on any strip
[Laughter]
he will chose face he's embarrassed I'd
be embarrassed if I got [ __ ] up by a
senior citizen he broke his finger yeah
so he could never swipe and throw the
pokeballs ever oh my god they stopped on
his hands yes dude super vicious what
are they did he fight raccoons what yeah
you caught these crazies
wait you don't look crazy that's the
thing this was an autumn run go back to
the landscape shot people need to just
there's two on what couple can open that
part jump in the water it was near the
bridge you can walk anywhere jump in the
water like Joe do this mall sucks out
getting away boy that's a lot of
spending that sad that he got [ __ ] up
but he also shouldn't be so beat up a
ball even good at being a [ __ ] cuz if
if I'm up a little [ __ ] and I and I'm
scared I know how to run I would have
jumped in the water
peed on myself do something but yeah
you're fighting dudes that bite the hand
what the [ __ ] is that
do you think they were like an empty
gatorade bottle at him and hit him in
the face well that's not anything we're
chewing government with the wrapper they
threw it on his face
dignity dignity generally what you just
told me was this local man throws
crumpled up card in girl's face did you
just go through your [ __ ] phone to
get that card no it was already sticking
up oh but if a fully loaded gatorade
bottle straight to the eye bone it was
empty
doesn't say I'm Diego my bed it's gym
fight so if you did wanted to take over
the fire gym or didn't be they lose I
don't know I know how this happened
their pop was like let me take over the
gym and then he's playing the Pokemon he
goes no no so instead of like fighting
bad huh
they were in vent in their cart in their
heart apparently the father and son were
in their vehicle in the car okay yeah
and then once the the gym was taken over
by the victim they got out feet is that
that's what I mean so when they're like
when the guy was on the untime out the
[ __ ] when he was on the phone instead
of fighting them in real life
he was just holding on no I'm not gonna
let go of the gym so that was that's why
there's no way and that's mother why the
the dad was like no give me your phone
and he he was like man like there's no
way you're not gonna run away if I just
go to the phone you had to be near the
place yeah let go on the phone and
attacked a dick yeah that's what he did
he was like too stuck on the power you
know what's weird - that doesn't look
like a place that's populated by many
people so all I imagine is one guy on
the on that little dock thing just on
his phone and in the - no son walked
over who does play pokemon go now again
the the cigar so I know I saw them
posting about knows links yeah but
they're so cute they are they're really
nice yeah I like the relations yeah what
their brotherly relationship does they
have a cute brotherly relationship idea
they took fight each other that that's
so cool yeah yeah dad the fire brother
like you know one of them I [ __ ] dick
fight them - would you
only if you put it in your mouth her
mother's the [ __ ] ring were like the
dick fights happen today
the brothers will come and [ __ ] dingy
by it what the [ __ ] do they sell them
you could make your own background and
tenure kundo [ __ ] [ __ ] rowdy rowdy Oh
Louie Joe also has another [ __ ]
background and BJJ [ __ ] Jitsu no job
Jitsu gonna win anyway yeah so they were
taken to jail and set the bail was set
$15,000 oh damn definitely they should
be in jail for at least 30 years just
because that's embarrassing yeah and I'm
not talking about the two guys I know
the guy who I beat up what was the
argument man that's some crazy [ __ ] some
crazy I wish America had more CCTV we do
they do report that a witness data
capture video of the fight but turned it
over to the police and I couldn't find
it hmm maybe after we'll find it I cut
it I gotta watch it man three people
fighting over Pokemon go some of the
[ __ ] some of the best things in life is
those like real fights caught by like
people just walking around but they're
from people that don't know how to fight
or like just nerd rage all that [ __ ] I
love those man please
[Music]